let's take a question right here from a
young fella right here come out jimmy
john one question
what do you get at jimmy john's
[ __ ] mind-blowing oh you like your
subway better
right on so i love a turkey time with
onions and oil and vinegar added to it i
love a turkey tom that way but if you
get it that way you got to eat it
immediately you can't wait
my go-to sandwich is the new east coast
hoagie so you got to get the new number
seven east coast spicy hoagie that is my
favorite one right now good
for sure i think it's the best sandwich
that we've ever we've ever done
i like the frenchie a lot but inspired
brands got rid of it did you have the
little frenchie nope i never had oh nope
i never had it never had i've always
gotten the turkey time except for
the last couple times i went i got a
club um
italians yeah italian nightclub yeah
number nine
so but i um i've been a turkey time guy
my whole life man i'm a real
i kind of stick with what works for me
you know uh
so you're 40. yeah i'm 40 now you know
now that i i'm just sitting here
thinking jimmy john's just part of your
whole life oh yeah 100
jimmy john's was only part of it was
half of my life
i i have a hard time with the obvious i
just realized
you were grew up with it dude it's crazy
so if i'm touring or i'm in a different
city and i wherever i get the first
thing on my way into
town i will see if they have a jimmy
john i'll just have them bring one right
to the hotel so when i get there i have
a jimmy john's man
it's one thing that i do feel about
jimmy john's is
it is as reliable a food
that exists out there i every time it's
going to be the same and it
always gets there fast man it's just
there it's like
it really is it's just there the other
[ __ ] i don't know what's going to happen
people somebody might get shot on the
way deliver i have no idea
but with jimmy john's it's straight up
now i had i actually got i had
got a i hooked up with jared from
subway's sister a long time ago in the
french quarter this is a long time ago
so i've had some some unique
interactions with some you know with
some sandwich
experiences over my life but um and then
i used to talk about quiznos a lot of
times
now quiznos went under right yeah and
here's why i think and this just is a
straight mail you know
quiz knows i would go into quiznos right
and you get the toasted sandwiches
toasted right which i liked it's cool
you know
but the problem with quiznos was there
was just men in there eating them so
when you have a toasted sandwich
and you're like bringing it up to your
mouth and it has like this kind of like
this big open mouth kind of vibe and
you're just sitting there there's other
men in there just looking at each other
it had this extremely homoerotic vibe
for me at quiznos
and i wouldn't bro and i think i really
believe that it hit a lot of them in
that way and it
it just it kind of made it too tough for
me to go get quiznos
and sometimes that it would burn my
mouth it would like
kind of chat me up a little bit and it
just felt kind of homoerotic eating
those in there because it was only men
in there i think they only really cater
to men
i i have no idea i never this first time
i ever heard this in my life oh this is
a big theory out there but
a lot of women won't go get a toasted
sandwich it just
you know there's a good toasted
sandwiches pot belly it's not dainty
enough i like potbelly they don't toast
them too hard right
i like that but um but anyway those are
some
sandwich experiences that i've had but
did you uh was there another sandwich
place you really enjoyed over the years
or
another business that you watched grow
over the years yeah i think that
uh let's what what businesses i i think
pretamanje does a great job no i'm
familiar with them they're they're
london-based mcdonald's owned them
and then they open some stores in new
york they do a really good job with
sandwiches
i think portillo's hot dogs did a great
job
this is go through out of chicago right
yeah yeah so my friend dick portello he
sold about the same time just about a
year before i did
so another another great guy i love
portillo's a lot
um what else do i respect a lot um
i really respect chick-fil-a how can you
not respect chick-fil-a
i mean what they do i mean my pleasure's
getting a little old but i respect it
and that's what they do and it's what
they say i guess freaky fast could be
getting pretty old dew
but um i think chick-fil-a has
incredible respect i think mcdonald's
new quarter pounder with cheese with the
fresh burger
i think it's an incredible problem i've
had that yet yeah they're using a fresh
meat patty now really it's really a big
difference it's big time yeah you ought
to try it how can you not respect in and
out
i mean it's kind of a grilled cheese
sandwich flavored with vegetables and a
little bit of meat patty but it's still
pretty damn good and the price is really
really really good yeah
um what else do i really respect a lot
was there a good brand that came through
that didn't make it that you were like
man what happened here because this
thing was
that didn't make it kfc i do not i i
don't
i'm a popeyes guy you know but i love
popeye's chicken sandwich
their their chicken is just if they made
a heroin i would buy it
that's so good popeyes is good if
popeye's made a heroin
dude i don't think america would exist
anymore but yeah there
there's just something about their did
you ever meet that guy uh what was that
al copeland yeah yeah and his son
really what was that like because i'll
tell you this so growing up in that area
he put the big christmas lights up by
the edge of the lake and
people would get pissed because they had
to drive their car by them and then like
people were like i'm getting old i can't
see the end of the bridge what i'm
trying
so there was always he was always this
like flamboyant like uh
bigger than the larger the life he was
like that was like my dad
but go ahead yeah he was just like that
he was like larger than life like
the big christmas lights and we're doing
this and we got a
you know you felt like he had a cigar in
his hand even if he didn't have it in
his hand you know
he was just larger than life he was he
was i used to watch his offshore
powerboat racing remember he did that
the cigarette boats he would take hot
girls back and forth from our town
over to new orleans and then bring him
back like a month later
a month later but i love that stuff so
much and i ended up creating a
or being part of an offshore powerboat
with the jimmy john's offshore part when
we won the world championship that way
and i that was all inspired by that dude
al copeland i thought it was so cool
i thought it was the coolest thing in
the world man it was uh
yeah he was a hero remember his
sunglasses and his gold chains
oh yeah big black hair oh yeah he was
killing it
he i ca i don't know if he was italian i
don't know what he was
copeland i'm not sure he wanted to be
italian yeah he wanted to be
for sure great call yeah he was a he was
the legend
around our town around our area growing
up because he was just
he bought this big place right when he
got off the causeway bridge in new
orleans
and they had he put all of his boats in
his truck everything was big he put just
it was
in these big glass windows you could
just see when you drove by for no real
reason
but just to be like hey this is what i
you know here's what's going on here's
my [ __ ]
i'm just sitting on your front porch
wondering how could i be so
far from my home
and my mind is somewhere else but when i
find it i'll patch up where it's been